kaiju number eight is a very new series
only starting serialization last july
but
in my eyes it has all the tellings of a
great new shonen
the concept itself is very similar to
attack on titan
which might be what intrigued me in the
first place in that while it takes place
in the modern day society is plagued by
kaiju
these big old monsters and the kaiju
defense force
a team of normal humans who use these
powerful suits that let them match the
beasts
are tasked with killing them and making
sure their harm to society is minimized
and on top of that the main character
kafka hibino
who's wanted to join the defense force
all of his life
unintentionally gets turned into a kaiju
or someone who can
become a kaiju at will and a really
strong and badass one at that
and as we follow kafka try and join the
defense force while keeping this secret
hidden
while also taking down these huge
monsters like one on one
is just a really cool concept and it's
definitely caught my eye really quickly
and i have a feeling that it can
definitely make waves in the anime and
manga community
if it continues going at the rate that
it is let's check out kaiju number eight
in this story in tokyo kaiju don't spawn
super often
but with the massive collateral damage
they create and threat
if gone unattended to there needed to be
some kind of weapon against them
i mean just watch any godzilla movie one
of these things even
falls over and it's hundreds of homes
and buildings crushed and innumerable
lives lost
and so in response to this tokyo or
japan
i guess created the kaiju defense force
just normal people who wear suits that
actually integrate kaiju dna or powers
or something
which allows them to go way beyond the
limits of a normal person
and use weapons that are like super dope
it's very shown in need actually because
these suits have a certain output or
percent of power accessed from a scale
of one to a hundred of course
it's a way of power scaling everyone
because the more of the suits power that
someone can draw out
the more powerful they are the stronger
they get
again it's just a great way in a manga
that doesn't have
like super diverse superpowers or
anything like that to show character
growth in its characters
and show them getting stronger and it
also reminds us that without the suits
they are just
normal people now the story follows
kafka hibino who actually has the job of
cleaning up the remains of kaiju
after they're killed by the defense
force kaiju don't just disappear
and so you've got a bunch of guys like
this who have to go in and export its
guts and move its body and stuff like
that
it's a pretty gross job and without
saying too much here
kafka has always dreamed of joining the
defense force despite having this job
now
and has kind of let the opportunity get
away with him since he's actually 32 now
and this is one thing that i feel is
really important it's totally different
and fresh to read a shonen manga
especially in
shonen jump that doesn't have a teenager
protagonist but
instead an adult someone who's mature
and that might be one of the reasons
it's so
interesting to me or captivated me so
quickly
he's already developed a really strong
moral compass and firm stance on how he
should act and save people when
or if he joins the defense force unlike
you know a 15 year old who just entered
freshman year but somehow gets tasked
with saving the world
not to criticize this kind of
storytelling of course but to have
someone who is older and more mature
is certainly interesting and really
uncommon within shonen
and so through certain events kafka ends
up becoming a kaiju or at least
a person who can transform into one at
will and not only does he look
super awesome but he's really strong too
and so from here we see as he tries to
join the defense force finally and
achieve his dream
while also having to hide the fact that
he can turn into a super strong kaiju
because if he did of course they'd kill
him society has no remorse for kaiju nor
should they
and so we see this internal and external
struggle in his character that's also
just really interesting
if he wants to save someone from a kaiju
what'll happen if he shows people he can
turn into a monster
how will they react will he get sent to
a lab for experimentation
will he be killed on site or will he
have to kill them
and the best part as i mentioned earlier
actually is that it doesn't matter to
kafka in the long run
how he looks to other people because he
has firm beliefs and he is
i guess for lack of better words already
a hero in the way he thinks and his
mindset
he puts others before himself almost all
of the time
but having to become a monster to do
that is an intriguing dilemma the story
leaves us with
and so just looking at you know how cool
the character is when he's a kaiju the
power scaling
the idea of a select group of humanity
fighting against monsters
it's in my eyes a telltale sign of a
potentially awesome manga
and by extension it can certainly become
a really popular anime
if or when that happens this kind of
story's general idea itself is done
pretty often with you know attack on
titan in a lot of ways
parasite with being half human half
monster and having to hide it
and of course a concept like this has
been done a lot in shonen jump and will
continue to be done a lot
but you know from differences like a
mature adult protagonist
although he can be pretty immature at
times to a very explicit power scaling
system that lets us watch our characters
grow
it uh it has a lot of potential it's
also only 25 chapters in so getting
caught up is no problem at all
it took me about an hour or two just to
catch up and it's a really fun ride so
far
and one that i really doubt you could
even regret
i mean it's just a really entertaining
action shonen and i can see it going far
i mean it's not perfect of course it's
not like it's some kind of masterpiece
if it avoids themes that it could
certainly expand on and use then it
could kind of fall flat as a really
basic shown in manga
you know both attack on titan and
parasite deal with the concept
of who is the monster as the main
character kind of bends the line between
the two
and people become more open-minded you
see the atrocities that humankind has
committed as well as the monsters and
you have to decide who is really the
good guy here
this is really important in a story like
this to extend
you know these big battles to a moral
and ethical dilemma as well
or important for any story really for
that matter with stakes like this
and where humans are fighting monsters
not being afraid to kill off characters
is also really important in my eyes
it's kind of essential when tackling a
thematic topic like this
but it doesn't look like kaiju's afraid
to do that
i mean no one important has died so far
which is good i mean we're only on
chapter 25
but with the way action is going and
just from seeing a couple fights you can
tell that
every character is fighting well aware
that this might be their last moment
so to wrap things up uh just read kaiju
number eight
that's about it no but seriously
definitely keep an eye out for what this
manga has in store it's got potential
and if it hits all these bases
thematically tackles the right ideas
it'll surely become big and it's
something for anyone who doesn't read
manga
if any of you are left by this point in
the video to watch out for sometime
in the future as always this has been
the anime culture corner i hope you
enjoyed the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you